a federal judge on monday dismissed the
federal trade commission's anti-trust
case against
facebook the case was seen as the
government's first
real effort to curb the company's
dominance after several years of
increasing political rhetoric against
the company and rounds of congressional
testimony probing into the business
the favorable ruling led to facebook's
stock rising more than
four percent monday and the company
hitting a one trillion dollar market cap
for the first time
in a statement the company said they
were pleased the court's decision quote
recognized the defects in the government
complaints filed against facebook
so what happened the fdc hinged its case
around
one figure in the original 53-page court
filing made back in december
the ftc estimated facebook owned in
excess of 60 of a market the government
defined as
personal social networking the ftc
didn't offer any
further details about how it arrived at
the 60 figure
what the 60 represents or what exactly
constitutes personal social networking
a term the government coined for its
argument and a federal judge honed in on
these ambiguities
judge james bosburg said quote the ftc's
inability to offer
any indication of the metrics or methods
it used to calculate facebook's market
share
renders its vague 60 plus assertion
too speculative or conclusory to go
forward
even if the ftc had better explained its
figure that market share is lower than
what antitrust suits are typically built
on
generally antitrust cases proceed when
authorities can show a defendant control
70 or more of a market though there is
no
firm legal rule dictating a specific
threshold
during the government's antitrust case
against microsoft for example
regulators estimated microsoft dominated
80 to 80 percent of the market
regulators were given 30 days from the
time of the ruling to refile the
complaint against facebook
but the judge's decision is a clear
indication that pursuing facebook in
court will be harder than expected
and more difficult than calling
zuckerberg back to congress for more
testimony
[Music]
you